she's never seen me
handling kids i know i'm very good with
kids i love kids do you believe i could
do this babe so i think that she should
trust me and get some confidence in me
when it comes to our son
all right daddy's gonna put you in the
car
i'm showing kobe around celina and i've
grown up here it's a small town
i know we won't have the social life
like he's used to back in china and in
africa but i hope kobe can see himself
and our family living here because we
can't move right now we can't afford it
it makes more sense to like stay close
to my parents where they can help out
set him in yeah watch his foot babe i
think i should drive because i
i think i'm a better driver than you are
yeah okay you're not a better driver
than me you're not gonna drive your
first time in america with cobin in the
car why
because you guys have a very big and
wide road that everybody can do whatever
you want but in my country you need to
be very careful
so i don't think you know you telling me
not to drive it's like it's like an
insult i don't know
i don't really care how experienced you
are in driving but i don't feel
comfortable you driving with copen in
the car
my old son
yeah in my car not your car it's my car
so are you going to get in the car or
not
even if i have to get it because i'll go
by myself even if i have to go in the
car but i'm not pleased just just so you
know that i don't care
china emily was sweeter like we had so
much fun
and the emily i'm seeing right now
no
she's changed a
lot can you buckle please
with the way things are going
emily feels she's already planned
everything i'm just gonna fill the space
but i'm not that kind of a person
i set my own rules and i live by those
rules as a man
[Music]
you